We all make mistakes,
we're all human,
and it really is time now
to find that forgiveness
for yourself,
otherwise you're going to stay
stuck in a cycle of blame,
guilt, shame
and self-punishment, and I know
from personal experience
that is hell on Earth.
So I woke up that day
and I was really excited
because it was our school
sports day that afternoon.
I really thought I was in with
a chance of getting a medal.
I walked over to
the runners' box
and I picked the javelin up,
I took a really deep breath...
...and headed towards
my friend Sammy.
I just collapsed onto my knees
with my head in my hands
saying, "Oh, my God,
oh, my God."
I just couldn't process
what was happening.
The accident was all over
the news, all over the media,
and I think my family wanted to
try and protect me from that.
But nobody really knew
what to do,
and so I was really
sort of left
to get on with things
on my own.
I already had
a very difficult relationship
with my stepfather, and on the
way back from Sammy's funeral,
he said that...
And so not only did I not
get any professional help
to come to terms with things,
I couldn't even talk about it
at home.
I just felt like I had to
pretend to everyone
that I was OK,
when really I was feeling
all of this mental
and emotional turmoil.
After that therapy,
it was like a weight had been
lifted off my shoulders.
In the moment when I realised
that I'd done nothing wrong,
I also realised all the pain
and the suffering
that I had created for myself.
When I talk to people
about self-forgiveness,
I've never experienced
such pain in a room.
It's far greater than
when I talk to people
about forgiving others.
Self-forgiveness cuts to
the core of our identity.
People often go on journeys
of self-discovery,
and Lis Cashin's
a very good example of that.
It took decades for her to move
to a place of forgiving herself
and then, in a way, then moving
beyond forgiving herself,
because she realised she was
a child, it was an accident,
there were adults there
who should have taken
the entire...
...responsibility for
what had happened
on the school playground
that day.
So the accident had happened,
but then it was me
that had created these
really destructive beliefs
about myself - that I was evil,
that I deserved
to be punished -
and I'd gone on
to punish myself
in many ways over many years.
And when I realised that,
it was like my heart broke open
and I developed
self-compassion,
and really needed
to forgive myself
for hurting myself
for so many years.
MARINA: I think
self-forgiveness is very much
wrapped up with guilt
and shame,
and this is why I think
accepting yourself
for who you are
is critical to everything.
It's about having this broader
perspective on life.
So for instance, in the case
where you may...
You may have had
a drug addiction in the past
and caused a lot of damage
to yourself and others.
You may then actually
broaden your perspective
to look beyond yourself.
Why had this happened?
It's an addiction.
It's an illness.
And that can really
make a change
to how you perceive yourself
and how your life progresses.
MARINA: By talking to others,
by exploring other people's
stories that are similar
to yours.
What happened to them?
How is it similar?
How is it different?
And then I think
key to everything
is self-awareness.
Going on a journey
to discover who you are.
Knowing yourself better.
Because if we don't know
ourselves, we become deluded,
very often, and we create
great damage in the world.
There's a wonderful quote
by the spiritual writer
Richard Rohr. He says...
LIS: So now I make it
my mission every day
to really practise
love and self-care.
I meditate every day,
I make sure I get out in nature
or exercise.
I have a really brilliant
support network of friends now,
and family. I'll reach out
for professional support
if I feel I still need it.
And now the thoughts
I have towards myself
are much more loving,
and accepting, and forgiving.
Some people have said that
self-forgiveness is selfish.
I don't think
that's the case at all.
Because if you can't
forgive yourself,
you are central to your drama,
and you're probably telling
everyone about it all the time.
Or if you're not,
it's in your head all the time.
Self-forgiveness
is about making peace with
things you've done
which you cannot change.
And also it's about accepting
that you are
a fallible human being
just like the rest of
the human race.